betty-lou your reaction as he's shown
the door I assume would you assume he
wasn't retired that he was essentially
shown the door let go yes I mean there
was a lot of frustration but first off I
want to test her McDonald's knowledge
can you all say this with me to all beef
patties
okay to a generation McDonald's was not
the hit right for us it may have been
look Don Thompson as Tom rightly put it
on you kind of you want to root for this
guy okay I mean he was born in a poor
neighborhood in Chicago he's raised by
his grandmother he started off as an
electrical engineer got a call from a
headhunter at McDonald's when he was at
MIT when he was at Sun Northup Froman
and said I'm never gonna be flipping
burgers what are you talking about went
to McDonald's stayed there for 25 years
and rose to the ranks being one of just
a half a dozen black CEOs in this
country okay this man has defied odds
time and time again but he just couldn't
do it when he when he had hit the helm
at McDonald's when he arrived in the CEO
spot
Jim Skinner had eight years of sales
gains in a row and McDonald's yeah his
first earnings call he had to oversee a
sales decline last year they saw their
first full year of a sales fall okay and
none of it is his problem okay Super
Size Me came out back in 2004 the
obesity issue was already around yeah a
minimum wage was already there the menu
was already unwieldy by the time he
arrives but there were several issues
that happened during his tenure let me
just name three of them first before
before you guys ask some questions okay
fall 2013 remember mighty wings yes big
flop okay they ended up with 10 million
wings unsold July 2014 expired meat in
China again another big controversy from
2012 to 2014 they had the extra value
menu nobody knew what the heck that was
they scrapped that and then they put in
the dollar menu and more which was like
extra value 2.0 so there was menu
confusion among consumer got it so they
tried all these things we saw a jalapeno
burgers we saw mixed skillet burritos
they really you know they even got into
premium coffee what actually worked of
the things Don Thompson
instituted I have to actually think
about it right because it's been so
negative look you know they did go out
and and on social media try to explain
to their consumers directly that their
food is real you know I went to head
their headquarters they make rap at the
time but this was a couple years ago was
that was going to be their big hit Don
Thompson and I you know we went to their
Test Kitchen we did the mick rap and
that by all accounts was also a flop it
and I want to just play for you one part
of what Don Tom said about inventing new
products at McDonald's customers want
more and more today to have a one-on-one
relationship with brands they want to be
able to understand what is it you're
going to add to my life what's special
value how are you going to differentiate
your your food or your products or your
services relative to what it is I want
is it customized to me can I just I just
want to say one more thing I was
thinking about this a little bit why is
McDonald so out of favor right I think
part of it has to do with that Americans
just have better taste these days
talking about the Starbucks vacation of
our neighborhoods right Starbucks target
with design other retailers they've just
introduced better taste to America and
well I think better taste is not
McDonald's but a shape and consumers are
demanding different things as Brandon
you were pointing out in the earlier in
the meeting earlier this morning
American consumers want to know that
those cows were treated well yeah it's
not about I mean McDonald's has a system
and I mean we have to sort of admit that
Don Thompson for all of for what he is a
product of the system and he thought he
needed to make new things with the
system he needed to fix the system right
exactly